[موسيقى]
هذه الهوايه بدات من الوالد الله يحفظه
ويطول في عمره
هو هاوي من صغره منذ ليونه اظافره وهو
يجمع كل ما تقع عليه يده ونحن بالبثل في
كل السفريات او في كل مكان بنزوره كنا
بنعود دائما بقطع التي نستطيع التحصل
عليها انا ذاك كهوايه حتى كبر المتحف يوم
بعد يوم وتقاعد الوالد من عملي كان يعمل
المعلم
وبدا بدايه جديده فلنقل
بهمه عاليه للمتحف خرس جهده ووقته كامل
لجمع المقتنيات ولعرضها عرض مبسط كهاوي
[موسيقى]
المتحف مقسم الى اجنحه مختلفه
فتجد مثلا قسم مخصص للسلاح الابيض في
مختلف قطعه
من خناجر من سيوف من عصي من رماح
وايضا
اقسام خاصه مثلا بالخشبيات والمنحوتات
اقسام خاصه بالاجهزه
والادوات الصوتيه
والسينمات القديمه والتلفزيونات
الفيديوهات الاشياء المسموعه والمرئيه
ايضا قسم بالملبوسات لمختلف الدول مختلف
الشعوب والثقافات يوجد بعض التركيز لبعض
المناطق في السعوديه ولكن اجمالا كما ذكرت
سابقا نحن متحف التراث الانساني
نتكلم عن الانسان في اي عصر كان
ايضا من الاقسام قسم المخطوطات والورقيات
قسم العملات والمسكوكات قسم الحرف المهنيه
بمختلف
اماكنها وادواتها قسم خاص بمكه المكرمه
ومقتنيات الحرم المكي
والاشياء التي كانت تستخدم في نفس الحرم
قسم خاص بالمنسوجات قسم خاص بالمناهج
الدراسيه القديمه
قسم خاص بالبقاله القديمه ونماذج لها
نماذج الاضاءه على عبر العصور ومختلف
الازمنه كثير وغير ذلك كثير
المتحف اسميناه متحف التراث الانساني لانه
حصر للانسان عامه في اي مجتمع وفي اي مكان
بدون تضاريس وبدون حدود او ديانه او فهو
انساني لكل ما استخدمه الانسان عبر
التاريخ في ادوات للزراعه من
اشياء اجبره على تصنيعها وعلى اختراعها
واجبرته الظروف لتطويرها
ثم تطورت حتى رايناها
في يومنا الحاضر بتطوراتها الجديده
[موسيقى]
يزور المتحف العديد من الجهات منهم
بالافراد ومنهم بالجروبات او الجماعات
فيزورنا الطلاب المدارس
ويزورنا الدارسين ومحضرين
الدراسات العليا
في المتحف قطع مختلفه ودائما ما نسال اي
قطعه مثلا ثمينه او غاليه ونحن كاصحاب
متحف وقهوه نقدر كل قطعه فيه
ويعني نفخر بكل قطعه في غض النظر عن السعر
او عن الندره فلكل قطعه قصه
ومجهود كثيرا ما سافرنا لوسافر الوالد وشق
المسافات لكي يحصل على قطعه واحده من داخل
المملكه ومن خارج المملكه فهي تعني لنا
الكثير
[موسيقى]